تنازع النفوذ بين فرنسا وروسيا على
افريقيا يدفع الرئيس الفرنسي مانيويل
ماكرون للتوجه للقاره السمراء في محاوله
للابقاء او استعاده الهيمنه الفرنسيه ان
صح التعبير بعد ان كانت لها اليد العليا
خاصه في غرب القاره عانت فرنسا انتكاسا
عسكريه وسياسيه في بعض الدول التي تحولت
الى الشراكه العسكريه والاقتصاديه مع
روسيا الرئيس الفرنسي القى خطابا خصصه
الاستراتيجيه فرنسا الدبلوماسيه والعسكريه
في افريقيا قبل ان يباشر جوله تشمل اربع
دول في وسط القاره وهي الجابون وانجولا
والكونغو وجمهوريه كونغو الديمقراطيه في
زياره تتركز على مناطق بعيده عن
المستعمرات الفرنسيه السابقه التي باتت
تتصاعد فيها المشاعر المعاديه لباريس جوله
الرئيس الفرنسي تاتي بعد اكثر من اسبوع من
قيام بوركينا فاسو بطرد القوات الفرنسيه
وانهاء اتفاق عسكري سمح لفرنسا بقتال
المسلحين في الدوله الواقعه في غرب
افريقيا لتصبح احدث دوله افريقيه ترفض
مساعده باريس فالعام الماضي سحبت فرنسا
قواتها من مالي بعد ان بدا المجلس العسكري
هناك العمل مع متعاقدين عسكريين روس ما
انها 10 سنوات من العمليات ضد الجماعات
المسلحه في مالي وانتشرت مجموعه فاجنر
العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه ايضا في جمهوريه
افريقيا الوسطى ما اثار مخاوف من تداعيات
على الوجود الفرنسيه في القاره سبق ذلك
اتهام ماكرون لروسيا بتغذيه دعايه مناهضه
لفرنسا في افريقيا خدمه لما اسماها
الطموحات الجشعه لروسيا
يجب النظر الى الدول الافريقيه كشريك
اساسي تربطنا به مصلحه مشتركه يجب خلق
علاقه جديده متوازنه ومسؤوله حان الوقت
لاعاده تحديد طبيعه علاقتنا مع الدول
الافريقيه وعلينا ان نظهر تواضعا كبيرا
عندما نتعاون معها لدينا توجه جديد تجاه
القاره الافريقيه وسنتعامل مع واقع امني
جديد في افريقيا
لقد قمنا طوال السنين الماضيه بدعم
شركائنا في افريقيا وتم تكريس اكثر من
ثلاثه مليارات يورو بين عامي 2019 و2022
في اطار الدعم للدول الافريقيه نعمل على
سياسه جديده للتعامل مع الدول الافريقيه
وسيكون وجودنا في افريقيا عبر قواعد
مشتركه مع الدول الافريقيه